this great big story was made possible
by wells fargo established 1852
re-established 2018.
almost every nationality on the planet
is represented in the neighborhoods of
queens new york which means the streets
are lined with food from around the
world and if there's one man who's tried
them all it's this guy
don't be fooled by his slight frame he's
spent the last 20 years unearthing every
hidden gem this side of the east river
we're here in downtown flushing
and there's all sorts of things here
including soybean chen flower shop which
is
of course
a florist but you might wonder why
soybean is in the name and that's
because they sell dough hua
or fresh flour tofu wonderful warm
custardy tofu right out of this window
i love this one it's really what a great
breakfast
[Music]
hi joe hello
cherry my sister how are you
scared pata paplan specializes in thai
boat noodles and it's a really funky
thai bar with this crazy decor and the
the owner's trip
where did you learn how to make the the
boat noodles i used to cook with my mom
when it was in thailand before i moved
to new york and then no other place that
make it in new york
necessity yeah that's why i try to make
it in here
one of my favorite tibetan restaurants
lots of fast food is nestled in between
you and me wireless
and little myanmar minimart one of the
best places
for tibetan beef momos if you think
you're lost on the way in just look for
the prayer flags
[Music]
what makes the momo unique is the masala
or seasoning that's in there so you find
szechuan peppercorn ginger celery
onion i like to think of them as the
hamburgers of the himalayas and i mean
that as a compliment
[Music]
the reason that places like this
resonate with me is because they're not
trying to make it the next it thing the
next instagram food it's just like hey
this is what we make back home if you
like it too come on in
queen says everything
go explore the neighborhood and find
what's out there it's super easy
accessible delicious and people are a
lot more welcoming and open than you
might think
[Music]
you